Huff's ago morels - Pierre - pack and
welcome to brothers a tale of two sons
this game that I've been wanting to play
for a quite a while I just never been
been having the chance to play it and
finally I can cross it off my list of
games I wanted to play the reason why I
wanted to play it because everyone just
seems to praise it so damn much there is
something special about this game I know
I know the premise Adam but we'll see
what that it's about in a second so I
wanted to do say that if you haven't
heard of this game before or if you
really like I want to play that that
looks cool feel free to stop at any time
and check the game out yourself I hear
this is the type of game that you really
should just experience and enjoy
yourself it's also a game that is kind
of built around finishing in one one
setting as far as I'm maybe that's not
entirely true but I think I think that's
what I hear so I'm gonna try to make
this into one video which might be a
problem because I hear the game is like
three hours which means this is the
longest video ever I don't know if
actually pull that off or not we'll see
but regardless let's blame this press
this is also a puzzle game and I'm awful
at puzzles and I probably won't edit
this as much this is a very long video
so this should be interesting I'm
looking forward to share these couple of
hours with you breaths it's gonna be a
good one you're probably gonna get a lot
of gray hairs of just watching me trying
to solve [ __ ] but you probably shouldn't
watch this at all to be honest but I'm
glad you're here
[Music]
his hair feels very adventure time like
I could just rip it off an eater or
something just me
[Music]
pull her off
with something pulling her down
like I couldn't she just take
still wanted there though
[Music]
still want to eat there oh she's a ghost
well that's sweet yee-yee
are they speaking the same language a
Russian da has everyone dying in this
game
is that our dad he has a great beard and
haircut pretty stylish dad red boots -
okay what are we doing here we have to
get down cool world looks cool I like it
very nice
much don't say it I'm sorry hold
triggers to interact did did it there we
go
oh my god
I'm controlling vote for the brothers
now what are they doing down there at
the same time which is a little funky to
be honest so the big brother is left
I'll just have to remember that our dad
is really [ __ ] sick man it's like to
try to break that is our subject look at
this oh god my coordination skills are
like the best ever so this should be
easy
don't worry papa coats we got your back
oh god oh god it's so weird my brain
cannot handle this
well bridge though I mean why just
finish building the bridge when you can
go interact somehow with these how do I
interact with them maybe the little
brother has to do it hello sorry
now the big brother should do it because
he's bigger which button was that
oh yeah I got it I got it
don't da me yeah I get it
oh my god don't have Tommy oh it took
him a while I have to hold it down he's
really loving that steak huh calm down
big brother all right yeah okay
now you now you're pissing me off yeah
just grab it what are you doing there
you go
god this is gonna be a long day dress on
me for me so you figure out the controls
Jesus it's so weird all right whatever
game what is this
now god I gotta wrap my head around this
uh is it broke there and some flowers
you you have to go up oh there you go
well that was easy let's not just fall
down and then interact there we go the
rope and then I go down and my dad is
still dying but ah oh god move oh god
what are you doing okay well he probably
has night yeah naives coming nice coming
all right here we go
it's so weird there we go
the barrel did something good today oh
god oh god alright thank you sir a brain
there we go yeah I know you like saying
yeah let's stop Tommy man god damn you
and you're a toss
sounds like Pootie Tang if you've seen
that movie there we go
wouldn't it be easier if the doctor just
came to us
I really okay he's barefooted that's not
very hygienic doctor if you ask me
yep great beards in this game I don't
know man it's one chance see I
understand what they're saying total
this scroll will go up his neck oh the
Tree of Life
[Music]
well heal your dad
like I just put it on my table what a
doctor are you
give him a get them out of pillow or
some [ __ ]
it's gonna be a brat okay we're free we
lost our mom we cannot handle losing our
dad so we'll do anything literally at
this point Oh God who are you you douche
don't me I have a scroll who do you
think you are you stick wearing douche
that's why he loved that other sixer Wow
amazing do a 360 I can't always get of
water because someday he's like it's
just water you idiot what the hell he
wants him to ride on his back see I
understand them even though they don't
speak English
old sugar to drag a little brother they
have a girl little brother wonderful
marvelous why are we going here yes oh
just because that do she wouldn't let
him pass us pass I would just punch him
in the dick
we did it oh well we got wet but we did
it how do we we can climb okay fantastic
arias again that [ __ ] screw that guy
trying to save our dad are come on Bella
fat Adama [ __ ]
luckily Oh God I got coordinate just
coordinate there we go
whoa whoa he said god damn mountain goat
can we jump imagine I don't know if it's
because I'm clicking or if it is and
there we go our little parrots a secure
socket it's a very pretty world it's a
pretty wire were living in Bros for
ChaCha's my hose oh good eye
gorgeous oh wow I don't know what
happened to synchronized dance hold all
Albie and rb2 rotate the camera
Oh God all right doing it
there's man sleeping there and people
fighting there hey go I did it come on
what do you want all right let's make
this guy up
no I'm just gonna sit here my dad is
dying but you know just gonna sit here I
would probably only just sleep if if I
was living here what is up with this
that so nothing else we can do
what about the little brother maybe he's
less anxious more anxious nope
all right well let's check Oh whoopsie
Daisy
Oh God is making a motion sick Shahadah
foul I'm at this
okay we need to wake him up somehow what
if we jump up again all right well leave
our brother for now oh he can go to all
right I didn't know that
oh god it's so hard to control if
they're in different spots like if
they're coordinated somewhat no never
mind anything I just said
yeah no we can just climb up here there
you go
the brothers of blue and orange got this
in the bag
got him in bago he's a little slow
oh that's okay Oh God because I'm slow
there we go beautiful
ah that ass hole I hate him he will pay
he will pay I will say how's he doing
now does he have nothing better to do my
god you the brother doesn't fit the big
run oh god that's an ugly dog you're
wearing lipstick you look fab
all right let's let this one out why
would they keep a tiny little dog like
that in the cage
come on kill kill Rufus kill well that
takes care of that half bad ha ha ha 5
yeah yeah yeah yeah all right where do
we go now synchronized ha ha ha I knew
he was working with the barrels
how did the dog get inside the fence
that one is sleeping in this goddamn
game how do we get past here
well we're here we act like dogs when
they can't things like
well I don't know is there something in
this well perhaps don't spit in the
whale what are you doing you don't spit
in whales that's the strap bottle did he
cheat on your wife again mr. Anderson
it's ok Anderson she exactly we get it
whoa that's a nicer dog let's talk to
this guy hello oh that's a cat that
explains it
can I pet it that it's oh my god well it
looks like he doesn't like you
okay let's keep going then everyone is
sleeping
hello it doesn't care what about the
little brother yeah oh my god are you
gonna do your job now you have one job
to pull a damn lever come on
oh now he's awake now we can ask the
brother
Oh see there's so many people like that
in other jobs in real I like you I can
relate when I skate only when I wait
we're free
we're out in the wilderness beautiful
very immersive this world I like it very
nice more sleeping people
everyone in this game has narcolepsy
that's that's okay she wasn't she points
as towards this direction because there
is so many other direction that we could
go what are you doing win let me show
you how it's done
you want the ball here's your ball okay
and you want the Buckeye fine hey Jamie
here they go
shoot alright I'll block it yeah Denard
oh oh dad passed oh oh my god she sucks
too much go yeah
we're just as bad as that other guy Oh
the ball is called banked and he will
join us throughout this journey this
epic journey of dad dad trying to figure
out controls Oh God well that didn't
last long there right here we go he said
four yeah so that means we have to go
here I mean we could just climb over it
nor anything at all of them but Big
Brothers tell us go here so let's just
do that why don't we get banked you're
still here good for you oh did we hit
them I thought we were gonna hit the
well what is with this game in Wales I
want the ball not the well there we go
see you later Bank perhaps in enough I
got an achievement for that that's
awesome
good I like when the world is really a
bet we're gonna go down here I like when
the worlds are really interactive it
feels more vibrant and alive
we see I use the word like I've been
trying to figure out how to do that for
years
marvelous you're welcome I know
butterflies sake I let the brother try
hello Holliday both oh hello they both
have different skills
it's always fun yeah where you were
definitely supposed to go here for like
a myth built of something though by not
crossing well it was whatever okay
that's cool
we got a drunken bastard who lost his
boots let me talk to him there we are
easy I can't drink that
if you drinking from his boat that's
genius
oh come on show some decency and respect
god damn it I don't even know breath oh
I swear all suck heart sake did you see
the squirrel suck y'all suck oh god
what's happening oh no it's a makeup dog
oh oh I get it he wants me he wants my
ass you want this ass I can distract him
hey oh oh go go go Oh probably should do
a better job at distracting this is
awesome Ron I'm sorry I'll never do that
again did it we're doing great for us
have five proud of you for doing nothing
for putting up with me I think that's
more than enough
okay I'll stop definitely stop there oh
I like Oh Road controller I'm sorry
sorry little brother yeah he's he's
trying it come on don't be mean just cuz
he's slow yeah
synchronize John what hmm
all right we'll need to help each other
get up then okay man the matrix kills
main um it takes a while but after a
while you started to get wrap your brain
around the whole control to people at
the same time thing it works
oh god that's gonna sing I almost spoke
too soon it works so weird apparently
you think you'd play like in some other
place interesting games one person holds
this one and another person holds this
one I think that would work but
apparently the the developer of this
game recommends that you play alone okay
it's like a co-op alone game alright I
get it
I'm the hamster I get it
all right that's cool hello sheeps or
just goes back up what yeah that happens
okay got it
oh I get it
oh my god ah the Sheep sorry sheep poor
thing
sheeps do we need what if I stand up I
never mind no no she yeah oh no the
Sheep was never seen ever again
oh my god no stay stay
if only we had that barking dog that
could help us hold it down or some shot
some shop get it no stay on the
godforsaken bridge please stay stay oh
god I can't
no what about now
what the [ __ ]
Oh supposed to go in the wheel I'm sorry
I'm numb
there we go I mean do you think about it
it should work my way as well
there you go sheep you're a hamster now
[Music]
Jane yes do we need more than one no
okay
that took me a while good job game I'm
an idiot you proved me and ever all the
brothers like they didn't know it before
but hey sly down oh you okay there
brother I feel like we're doing great in
your beds down so far I haven't been
stuck anywhere and I think that that's
pretty impressive for a puzzle game
considering I'm playing it when he says
after it's kind of like yatta and since
I'm [ __ ] such a weeaboo I know that
means anyway I hear something it's cool
I you can still see that doggy what is
he doing someone is crying inside a
bottle oh well you're ugly I would
probably cry too to be honest if
mushroom was growing on my back
it's not a very good oh I like his bed
little heart it's cute
oh there's two beds wet where's your
partner
[Music]
it's not easy hi to people oh it's so
cute
don't let him see his nipples okay maybe
this time he seemed safe daya is he
going with this
no we're going inside this too
it's cool to see all those things you
can interact with okay alright well
ladies first
like a mermaid will pop out of some [ __ ]
alright he's showing us the way
lead the way you troll man what is he
doing oh my god help it's not gonna stop
he throw me you can't do that
come on don't throw me whoa
it's like poke balls No can we sit down
so that's where we're going out with it
soon whoa this game is pretty epic it
feels like going on an adventure
I love it that's our game should be
we're going to that I don't know that
cave it looks pretty far though and
dangerous oh god are you gonna flick us
again I don't like it Oh oh that one
okay you got to remember which one is
which otherwise you're effed there you
go
of this hold down bow for them for now
thanks troll appreciate it
have a good life and a great afterlife
and a great next life after that okay
I'll stop
go oh god I almost died and you don't
Nighy me alright
don't you dare nay me alright what do we
get yeah you really love pointing at
things don't you
it's that easy cut ice coming we need
your help again let's push this looks
like the one from Zelda the ones you
pull up yeah okay you need to you need a
shell
ah stepping on his fingers
oh oh he's a bridge don't fall now I
probably will hurt like the poor sheeps
poor she's resting sheep here we go here
we go here we go here we go
hmm it looks like we can climb hell yeah
yeah
hmm are we are we going then okay let's
go little brother first and big brother
ah all right whatever
oh god this is really weird
I'll wait for the troll there we go oh I
made me nervous it's really weird you
have to think like okay
the left one there right oh god I have
to touch his pimples that is a nasty go
up oh yeah little brothers this one you
don't want to lose the grip now there we
go we did it
how about my hands are cold ah sorry
it's a head five I had just invented it
don't worry about it we need the troll
again I think high five it looks like
there I'm gonna spin five yeah yeah have
you ever done that coming up with all
kinds of original [ __ ] throw me which
which game is that when they fill them
oh yeah it's Kimberly and Lord of the
Rings throw me
I love their climbing technique I think
we need the troll master again no we can
do it now brother big brother has
problem and I don't know why yeah we go
let's just make sure he's safe all right
I did it
oh yeah my brain cannot handle two at
the same time
oh actually maybe it can and I need you
to Africa oh it is hard I know you
probably just think I'm an idiot for not
pulling it off but like it's harder than
you think
hey troll so he's coming with it seem
like I wonder how far whoa what is this
what we're gonna do left or right what
is he doing he wants both that's what is
he gonna do oh you cray cray it's gonna
matter eyes whoa what uh well that went
better than expected
Oh ready all right
let's take a break here all right took a
little break a broker there we're back
the brothers uh uh oh yeah he can't swim
I forgot [ __ ]
sorry brother I'm sorry my my bro okay I
got this go into water and then you
could grab on to him there we go there
we go it works gorgeous it's what it
looks so clear I just want to like they
look like they had like alcohol or
something change then you can do it you
can do it it's just water
high-five you did it when I was a kid I
remember you know when you're young and
you have those things in your arms to
swim like it really young remember I was
like [ __ ] those I'm gonna swim without
it so I jumped in and I nearly drowned
true story great I was genius even as a
kid
okay the troll told us to go in here how
wonderful and beautiful and magical this
game is magical because it has trolls I
think that says in a book somewhere if
you look in the fine lines Oh what do we
got here can we both go through I don't
think that brother can needs to fight
but not worry sir there we go then take
care of that bad let's take a look at
the view I don't know why I like this
benches Big Brother don't whoa this
reminds me of the great minds of Moria
it seems a little bit Lord of the Rings
inspired it takes you a while to
remember ok left stick brought Big
Brother's a right stick small brother
wait up brother big brother
all right if I can keep them on the
right side - it's a lot of you
yeah
go little brother Oh God
Oh okay we just let go Oh Africa it's
awesome
oh god oh god
jumping it's fine oh god don't Josh
don't DA me it's generally a bad idea to
control both when I'm at the same thing
ever again
whoa daddy Brad high-five ow ow what is
this place who built this this is
awesome
if I were these kids I would go in all
the time but I guess the troll wouldn't
really help them all the time where are
we going Mart is this do we need to lift
this summer
yep the where though I have no idea
let's just bring it I'm sure we like it
they wouldn't just place it there for no
reason am i right am i right or am I
wrong or am i wearing a thong oh we need
to walk like this got it
genius absolutely genius of me of course
because I'm the ultimate bro and you're
just the hole
hey ho I'm sorry that was not called for
I hope we need this cuz I don't really
check down there
is there anything down there that we
maybe we need to stop that thing or
something the cogwheels
could that be it yeah yeah yeah that's
definitely it oh how we did this without
even talking to each other we'd be like
oh yeah oh this is tricky though and get
stop it no one likes you
sorry it goes trying to sit in my lap
drinking loser there we go doing great
so far the puzzles are pretty
straightforward I would say they kind of
kind of sold himself to be honest what
is okay you go there I go there well I
would assume we go this way first
that's half the bridge okay um guys no
guys there you go guys good job
whoa that's a weird a lever
thingamajigger you'd think it would be
enough to with this one but I guess ah
don't fall down it would be fun if they
walk like this in real life they're like
ah don't understand I don't g says
sometimes I mean if you're walking in
there both same direction it's easy but
controlling two directions at the same
time is listening to one direction and
five shots at the same you just can't do
it
fangirls be happy you're too short I get
it air began marvelous oh it looks like
we have to leave our love brother ham
let's go up
Oh Oh see nap see you nap ZN up that's
what we call mustard in swedish the more
you know stand up mustard
next time you're in sweden you and you
wants a mustard on your halal and you
just yeah you have no idea what I'm
talking about
it's okay you're still pretty then
average I mean I don't want to give you
too much credit
oh yeah well let's check this out this
looks too pretty not to investigate guys
there you go oh my god this oh my god
fish a.i fish oh so you like this kind
of water huh a little bit of Cologne
there in there I mean Hanson oh my god
fish a.i fish a.i
why was this not told when i bought the
game i should have known about the fish
a.i I just oh my god I can't believe
they didn't market it is that I can't
believe wow faciai and they don't even
tell us about it I felt like I the price
of this game is too low now it should be
way like 60 bucks like the call of duty
alright here we go oh we were supposed
to go here maybe
what do we got here it's a bit creepy
here isn't it
I don't know what this is baby huh up
big brother first Oh big brother wait
for me now you son of a I know you
weren't trustworthy all right my turn
all right my chin is itchy
ah and I have to hold down the triggers
oh my god why does it have to h
everywhere right now
all right left one word about God thank
God oh yeah yeah okay is that don't let
go the wrong one oh my god it's like
when you know you can't eat it just
starts itching more there we go all
right let's see what little brother has
to do oh we need to open okay
ah jaysis I only got smushed kids
spreading keep spending keep spending
punched what are those lights the hell
is that
come on can I do it in time come on
yeah boy high five can do because I have
to yeah all right let me go hurry hurry
hurry hurry hurry hurry hurry I am
eating curry today everyone's for you oh
cool that's my turn to grab one what is
this doing oh that will sling me across
one it I'll look there's a little I
didn't see the troll sir they're down
there working on stuff whoa I'm pretty
sure this can't be the intents and
purposes of these mekin oh yeah yeah we
did it doing great great flow in this
gameplay I like it
keep doing it I'm like twirling around
here you like it don't you you're lucky
when that make this a is vibrate okay
another cream
when can I let go oh great there's a
show is that what Oh wrong way wrong way
sup now my butt is itching I'm sorry
rabbit nope
now scrap it already yeah I would be so
scared I would be just poop my pants and
probably like fly to space or some [ __ ]
some [ __ ] get it hilarious I know I do
try
I do try it seems when I think about the
controls the less I think about the
controls the easier it is to control the
less I think about control it easier
okay anyway
hmm is it oh it's climbing time
conveniently someone placed a bunch of
rings here thank you whoever came up
with that idea brother big brother has a
bit Oh God that is awkward
big brother seemed to have a bit of a
problem with the climbing I don't know
he I think he'd be the better one but
what do I know
oh god I don't like this oh thank god
whew they did that without a hesitation
I would probably try to climb up and
jump across instead it looks like you
could do that and way easier oh look at
the view
synchronized said hey they are the troll
still looking down
what are you doing down there I'm
talking to you well they're they're
blind I mean they're death there we go
okay big brother can you thank you
synchronized up oh they both suck now
what is this what are you doing
what the what the fudge cake what am I
doing here oh they just climb up okay I
thought they had to jump up Jesus no
wrong come on
again Oh God the climbing man the
climbing I don't like this one bit
I'm just there you have it huh
that just broke my heart a little bit
cuz first time we die alright let's just
do one at a time oh this makes me
nervous man oh my god
oh my god all right big brother time yes
oh thank god oh my god I think this is
both at the same time we're designed
this I love the voice I game Wow Wow
it's me when ate a sandwich that is
really
exact same noise how did we end up here
what the fudge happen Oh God
keep running don't question it whoa
oh my god it's collapsing poor trolls
they built this for centuries and we
just turn it up whoa oh there she is
who who did that to you is that the
girlfriend yeah
yeah we're not a troll we understand
does he have the cob he does have the
car oh oh it's right there how can how
convenient well the big brother loves
six so let's do it
and that [ __ ] is vibrating the [ __ ] are
you guys doing alright I can't walk
farther okay we can't split up too much
there we go okay got it
careful now Naheed I've got this bunch
of bones
Oh God I wasn't supposed to walk into
things oh oh oh well there's brutal
deaths in this game everybody a little
bit of limbo it isn't it yeah right
sorry about that I should have seen it
coming before I literally saw it like as
soon as I there you go
attention not tension I wish we saw the
death trap so we'd be more cautious or
whatever grab it is mmm yeah went
through with that oh you need to grab
the key sir thank you
now heed if that is your real thing Oh
God every time it's like the itch tests
of itch this game starts itching
everywhere alright there we go
and we go you're free and now we set you
three power of three will be on D
everything wonderful absolutely
wonderful you're free where's my four
high five I'm gonna call her moose
please
that's her name mush this nice song
smooch kiss oh no she's hurt
oh no well how about a thanks come on
oh-oh-oh-oh
can we have in the car go in the car no
we did it
nice I guess we need to trick him inside
the couch yeah that makes sense
come Sekai my cup stop going out
nice haircut the yes hello there mr.
troll ah ah you're trapped
wha oh yeah oh yeah a batch that is
awesome oh oh well if you told us about
that maybe we didn't have to risk our
life for a damn troll well now shut up
troll no one likes you you have a great
haircut but that's all you got working
for you really why did she have to
damage mousses oh I have to do it well
of course well brother has some problem
there you go oh hello the coordination
sometimes just doesn't want to do it I
am very sorry
I assume we have to go here
yeah the pulse is all very
straightforward what I would say but I
like it it flows well in the gameplay
you don't no one likes puzzles where you
just get stuck for hours I guess some
people like those puzzle [ __ ] we forgot
about us yeah okay now I am having some
serious problem there we go
I don't really think about any matter
matter about us I guess we can jump
across she's damaged look she can't be
as badass as we are right now or - hush
hush please
I'm gonna call the other troll at
Portuguese yeah beautiful name should be
proud there we go
high-five what is she doing she's waits
for us at least this time thank you
which case are you okay though you don't
look too good thanks
ah
in Sakai that's adorable we made them
reunite spank that booty come on no all
right just meet
Oh oh that is so cute oh come on how did
you stop how much beer do you drinking
on me I gotta troll this smarter than we
are
this is awesome what does this lever do
yeah okay I should get it
hello
[Music]
great job now if you could take care of
this changeover that'd be great look at
the shadows and it's awesome this guy's
very pretty for an indie game I mean
come on get some credit
I like how the little brother is the one
that always has to be in danger
alright let's see if we can time this Oh
No yeah come on pull it ah it's a time
is better there we go oh oh oh no step
on his fingers take a limp ah teamwork
let's do it together [ __ ] that is
fantastic
[Laughter]
hope gazing far she is it's gonna be
okay
oh I ship them so much yours have no
idea
that way all right got it
by can I give them a hug or something
Fisher yeah bakumaru [ __ ] oh ma okay
that probably means goodbye hope you
make many ugly babies
I would assume oh so we passed the mind
some Aria now we're going to man tomb
really you're just gonna stroke his nips
that's not gonna solve anything
[Music]
I don't psyche
what's going on here is there something
about the Stars and now we're back at
the brothers how does it work and it's
night now hmm wonder what dangers yours
and then oh hello look at I there's
wolves that's awesome a.m. oh did we
built that or was that there there
probably was there am I scared of fire
no I'm just bull normal to fire like the
most most things eh
stay close little brother bench that's
right
I'm the boss you don't even drink sauce
do you okay now I really need to figure
out how to control these two because
know what I don't want to get Wow
it's kind of kind of Warcraft healing to
it the graphics it's like cartoony but
Oh
what the hell I didn't know wolf
supporter capable of this
the [ __ ] is wrong with me
they're everywhere it would suck if the
fire went out we'd be dead right there's
light here why why is it or light here
oh now he'd need Jesus thank you Oh
chicks mine my nips fell off dawn oh
come on oh my god I was just not being
cautious just bided eyes like that like
Mohini come on luckily the penalty for
Deaf is nothing more than a tiny heart
attack a graveyard oh I don't need this
why is it so late just from the lights
and candles what is this mysterious
wonderful and Blair is it's a bell here
what does that do you did we just call
upon the spirits of the Dead like in
Dark Souls yep I like his hat hello set
sorry to wake you up Tom Murphy got it
otama feet got it oh he's coming with us
to show us that's awesome thank you he
seemed to really struggle but he seemed
like a good man considering everyone
else is narcoleptic in this game I guess
they sleep during the day and yeah he
looks like he's wearing like a oh sorry
huh oh well I think you say he looks
like he's wearing a diaper when he walks
I'm just Oh God Oh God did we dried them
Oh
Oh help him oh my god they stick a
strange turn of events who put these
candles here now whatever it looks get
beautiful let's go with it oh my god we
need to stop somewhere right swim Oh God
Oh God waterfall waterfall oh that was
close
damn this game is epic like I'm really
getting into it and I'm starting to
understand why they like it so much
which is always a nice feeling a bench
bench station
gotta love my bench station so we're
going down there that's
apparently where we're supposed to go
unless you're a bro or a whole girl
unless you're a bro or a ho oh god more
climbing I am not very good at Oh God
it starts itching on my nose as soon
oh god oh god oh god oh [ __ ] I don't
like this oh no no okay what's supposed
to happen oh my god no no no no we got
stopped ratted come on oh no oh oh grab
it now
Oh Dan
that has to hurt man
now you yeah right
that does not look any safer than
anything else I wonder what happens if
you go with a big brother first I wonder
if that luck has any difference oh jesus
[ __ ] christ oh my god this game just
wants me to have a heart attack don't
think Oh what just happened
oh yeah here hold said oh my god okay
and I can't cut what thou oh my god my
faith is nature this struggle of playing
this game you have to hold down the
bottom constantly I am sorry okay
Oh God well you don't do this [ __ ] every
day I never heard of trees thumbs being
against you this is news to me but they
do look creepy so anything creepy is
just set out to kill you I think that's
like the rule of Darwin or some [ __ ]
doing good
keep it going looks like we have a
moment we can go up over there I don't
want to die now you know alright it
looks safe here
oh never mind seriously you dick oh we
were supposed to okay
Jesus this game just takes a lot of
strange turn of events save Naheed oh
god I have to save Naheed oh god keep
going come on it's your brother
oh he's magnetic that's awesome come on
what happened they would save him can't
gain now
why isn't this game called sisters
sexist sexism in games hmm I'm sorry I'm
just kidding there is something special
about the ridership of about what that
[ __ ] is that what the actual you're just
approaching that like it's nobody's I
could be a giant potato though no it is
oh hello well
you could literally go inside our
nostrils oh she's holding the dad I
didn't see that this is some weird [ __ ]
what kind of drugs are you guys on well
the water drugged hello oh he's having
out okay
Wow oh I'm unconscious they'll probably
ah thank you Oh what the [ __ ] run in
front of your mother so he was
resurrecting him from death got it
this is a weird way to do what I would
say
all right break it down you two that's
enough I mean it you okay after wha I'm
gonna say that next time what the WHA
high-five yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right cool we are in a new area and
the night is over it's a short night but
I'm okay with it
cuz the wolf is scary uh-oh
what is he doing is he trying to kill
himself hold him up or shoot the [ __ ] am
I supposed to do I were trying to break
their thing why was he trying to kill
himself
whoops
we couldn't save him oh I wonder if that
has any consequence god damn it we
[ __ ] up I [ __ ] up I'm sorry bro what
the hell what was that all about
so it isn't the perfect world out there
huh
people still I mean it looks so cute
okay I get it
you and your finger-pointing man I'm
sick of it
oh well that doesn't really help does it
I see what we got here we're probably
gonna grab one of those right can I can
i oh oh
whoa hello well I guess that works yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah whoa did you hear that
someone is screaming in pain what the
hell what's up with this what is this
place I mean we saw a bunch of hang
dudes before all right what is this do I
think we have to run for it
Oh God okay go go go go you're my hope
okay never mind never mind I don't have
to do [ __ ] was easier than I thought
then that's okay cuz I'm doom straight
up dude
if the brother keeps to the left and
they're all been stationed in station
okay what did we get
and abandon old castle on top of a that
seems like a weird place to build the
castle I'm just saying if I was a
architecture I'd probably be just be
like I smell it somewhere else guys
Madison seem safe to me I'm okay we're
just building on top of the all right
but hey it's a magical world now he'd
come on I don't even know the name of
their bigger brother cuz you just keeps
yelling naheen sir oh that's not how you
do it
don't look down you'd probably just die
a horrible death it'd be a quick one but
a horrible one hear me out
looks like we're almost there
where we have to make it back then again
so it's like they're in Beck again oh my
god are those gorillas
those are gorillas aren't they
now they're what the actual there's
something at least don't attack us we
come in peace
now I'm gonna ride you [ __ ] yeah
this is awesome
hahaha oh my god this oh they're
mountain goats they can jump like
pollicis drinking salsas on the mic this
is awesome Oh
oh yeah that is awesome look at a look
at you're not looking oh snap oh I'll
take the know what little brother let
brother there you go little brother
yay what's uh if you don't know where to
go
just ride up map didn't gap if you [ __ ]
up
hey let three thanks goats have a
prosperous life that's not a sentence I
just I I thought it sounded good I try
to be in tonight show me the goats
yep that's me alright this is the bridge
Oh Albert Einstein okay yes I do agree
with you
oh the cogwheel yeah yeah I'm gonna say
that next thing yeah ii sweden there's a
dialect that if you want to say yes to
something instead of just saying yes or
any word at all you just go so anymore
you know it's actually kind of funny how
lazy you aren't you do it's like do you
want to go out cycle are you trying to
be a vacuum or do you want to go out
it's like okay I'm just gonna be funny
here and it's not working how do we get
the cogwheel over doesn't seem like you
can jump with it
how do we maybe we can catch it to each
other oh my god a puzzle I'm stuck on I
don't know can we
no oh no that does it
wait like it was nobody's business
oh [ __ ] did not expect that I just walk
across these controls man sometimes it's
a little little infuriating I would say
it looks like I will have to throw it
but we throw it like it's made out of a
[ __ ] made out of [ __ ] learning I'm
just kidding okay you think it would be
easier for him to just pass it up here
but I wanna wanna know about life keep
spinning keep spinning oh yeah oh yeah
yeah oh is it going why does every old
people walk like their have poop in
their pants
nice carpet where are you going come
back here his haircut looks like a brain
it's pretty awesome
yes that's how Einstein was so smart all
right what do you got for us your
backpack is spinning it's kind of
awkward haha is that it what is going on
here
does he need something from us okay
we're just gonna keep walking
Oh a Thomas Cobb I like this place is
cool what can we see doesn't seem like
there's any people strange yeah I don't
know about that oh wow whoa what is that
what are we gonna we get it oh we
getting it okay what no [ __ ] way
to the left to the left this is awesome
oh oh it's secure music man I don't buy
you guys when I'm rolling lines like
that cave oh well do what you want
let's see it's your life what do I care
[Music]
god damned is epic miss that feeling you
know when you go on an adventure I like
it
and we're gonna fly all the work whoa
whoa oh [ __ ]
god damn Birds oh oh are we gonna deal
with are we gonna market cuz it doesn't
look very shiny
oh shut that is not how flying works oh
god go left right oh [ __ ]
we're losing too much LT Todd oh there's
no way we can do it we're dead
you might as well oh nevermind we did it
oh he probably spent like months
building that thing where we made it to
the castle hold Nadeau is that - is that
the place they have the same
we can use the rope genius now can jump
skipper what oh you're gonna climb oh
[Music]
hell no I'm not that good at climbing
I'm just not I grab a B all right press
we can do this I believe at you and I
believe I do
I mean I believe at me because I have to
do it but I know you believe in me so
thank you for doing it
focus your mind like just look like
you're constipated because that seems ah
see what happened do wait I'm not
playing around here make that constant
there we go that looks great
you look L expect a good look on you so
what am I supposed to go then
oh oh oh your constipation man
damn it works
ah wrong one
[Music]
[Applause]
don't let go of the wrong one Wow oh my
god that pressure is real israel is real
okay what do we got here though I don't
like this brooch achos keep looking for
constipation ah did that on purpose
god dammit oh okay we just climb up now
now what okay he needs to come over here
uh which one was it
[ __ ] Oh oh my god it's really intense to
do this I'm pressing down so hard like
I'm gonna get like hemorrhoids in my
hands or some weird [ __ ] what did I just
say
whoa and that's how it's done and that
time with bang that time with then we
made it through that all around mean
like how the Rope just goes through the
ground because my night oh no aah boom
ha ha ha okay that was a joke
I think so much it's not a lever trying
to hide from me don't act a meme right
well we have to climb it Matt the
climate okay okay the itchiness man if
you are prone to itchiness don't I would
not recommend this game it's not your
game
okay what about now okay I can jump okay
ah climb [ __ ]
every wall we have to ah all right sorry
about that I messed up I'll admit to
messing up but sometimes you can't play
perfectly let's all right let's just
walk around look at the background is so
pretty except that giant line that goes
across the mountain but besides that
it's very pretty
uh-oh what is this place it must be
ancient
it's pretty epic though
I'll come on there we go
whoa Oh bro why don't we just oh god oh
god
the struggle is oh my god
Oh Maggie anything it feels natural
though Mary niet Charles DVDs we could
just let go yeah oh well calm down calm
down
there we go we did it high five breast
[Music]
looks like we have to climb now what no
in our way oh well that does it
cool and then he swings maybe yep that
works what about your brother hey hey
hey hey okay you need to grab on to
something seriously there you go
no not you okay you should be fine
anyway right come on just jump up there
you go
boom I thought we wouldn't make it for a
while okay look you can see inside the
castle like giant Olivia or some [ __ ]
what is over here how can I want to
investigate just for the fun seas come
on guys one at a time
there we go oh there's nothing okay well
you don't know if you don't look and we
did get an achievement for throwing down
a bowling it well so a tiny little girls
Bowl
she's probably crying about it still at
at home like to her mom me why why did
they throw down the bar mom and their
mom is like some people just want to see
the world burn Maria I just want the
world to burn but why mom whining
but brother was my only friend
well that's because you're a loser no
one likes you Maria that's a different
that's a different issue all right
moving on
it looks like yeah what is that sound
this looks weird okay what is this I do
not like it I do sir okay we still have
this oh hello
they don't seem to care at all come on
can't you jump No
okay we have to walk like this for some
reason hello why they don't even care
cool guys don't look one floor is
falling down they just let them all
floor down and Wow I think that's the
lyrics I'm not entirely sure though
ladies first
well what's the problem here
what am i what am I supposed to go in
here no help me
what did I miss okay we're supposed to
walk down here got it I got it all right
there we go got a little luster but hey
that's okay because I'm nothing never
mind
okay well what do I know then wasn't
Leslie walk back all the way this is
really strange
why won't they walk there what's the
matter with you guys
they don't want to walk anywhere this is
so weird
ah what am i gross
am I missing something obvious here what
about here oh oh oh okay I thought for
sure we were going downstairs okay my
bad my bad
drinks on me Prez drinks on me next time
we see drinks on me and then you got a
pee and then I'll run away
[Music]
hopefully someone is farting but it
sounds like something very creepy you
can always hope for farts that's what my
mom always said oh god oh god you
cray-cray
what happened did I take a shortcut ha
ha ha
are they both up yep magic I believe Oh
boom ba boom ba
we have to go inside uh uh me first
I don't know what I feel about this
pretentious do not the feel of what I
don't know
it's probably sleeping that's a bird oh
we could ride that bird oh my god that's
perfect
where is the master he keeps the bed
very tidy though
oh he's gonna come from that oh uh why
not the books at that okay I love these
books if you like it then sure to climb
the birds oh really
that's that okay you know what I don't
know what the [ __ ] you guys are doing
but I want you to stop there you go I
I know something bad is gonna happen
he's way too what he likes hmm
I want to see how the little brother
reacts to this alright little birdie
don't want to make waker oh he's great
at drawing at least Jesus like if these
were on deviantART everyone would just
be like oh my god you're so talented
yes all right the little brother has to
go through release right now I want you
to go through the catch no stop humming
for the love of God stop humming why
doesn't he want to go through
there you go come on I tried so many
times I tried so many times sorry so but
the brother wasn't really necessary I
hope at least here we go handle well it
works there we go
yes teamwork my bunch I see my snake he
just leave his brother haha I took it
that's oh it's all dusty
it's a Griffin thingy kind of sorry my
balls Richie ah de we saved you
now fly us to safety thought for sure
giant would come up and be pissed that
we sold their bird but I guess the giant
even is long gone they didn't they
didn't leave the bed very tidy
okay this I would not do this Nate's is
awesome I love it
[Music]
beautiful
Fiona
Thank You Sven okay yeah that's on I
shall miss you your courage will not no
guess it was too late
[Music]
what a great dad take his son fishing
I guess I really haven't given us much
reasons to why they dad is so special
until now like could be an [ __ ] for
all we know
let me hover this hand above your arm to
show how much I care
oh that is sad though I liked him right
back
wonderful did you miss me it hasn't even
been a second for you
strange Oh time flows for people in
videos don't hey nahi me i rhymed oh
holy [ __ ]
it's sick whoa is that one of the Giants
what is it blah I should not have had
that much snacks it's coming out of my
belly what is happening those tiny
brakes where the game takes over I'll
take them to scratch my [ __ ] oh oh oh oh
oh it's a fallen warrior a great battle
taking place what uh there's so many of
them oh god ah that was gay gone mad I
don't know what they're called in
English those but the evil ones from
Lion King don't like them they're evil
they're pretty ugly too anything
unglazed evil as we learned from from
history and that's an awesome maze and
what that maze nice toenails he keep
them pretty well I would say oh don't
lick it now he'd god they're everywhere
it looked like a recent battle - then I
mean if they're still
oh we're we're gonna push his arm oh my
god that is some freaky [ __ ] man that is
probably heavier than we can push let's
be honest it'd probably be easier to
just climb over it but hey what are you
gonna do great toenails in this battle
these swords are epic man how did they
even get we're gonna climb this oh go
away what are we gonna do then Oh got it
Oh God disgusting
we're not going down are we no we're
going here No
dah all right well you said it sister
grab em never count thank God you should
look after your little brother more man
you know he can't swim
got a little hot Claire the water is
this vital of the Deaf that's been
around right we did it
mm-hmm yeah we're going here can't get
it you guys can't reach it I get it I
get it
all right I thought we wouldn't take a
shortcut by doing that directly but I
guess not here we go up you go now he'd
go and I hate I'm proud of you know he'd
you're my favorite now eating out of all
nights I ever met and you're I probably
met another night heat actually I think
that's a real name yeah it's fine it's
flawless just pull him down
Oh or that there we go I should have
been a thing where they brought little
brother had to go back first or
something that'd be more tricky but I
like I said I like how there's a lot of
straightforward are we gonna tickle this
man's bead like next time you push him
trying to actually touch him like
germophobia is these these two whoa whoa
oh well okay
oh my god this game is crazy so many
things I would like never expect to
happen I like that we're slide and girl
or more Blood River wonderful absolutely
wonderful how much of a river to be
honest
I bet we're gonna go back what is this
okay there we go
careful Oh another arm
hello conveniently they got shot in the
arm
there's no blood there though come on
yeah oh we didn't really think that oh
my god that is nasty
hahaha oh my god that's actually awesome
for a guy well I guess it was dead but I
wonder what happened I'm set up in
station I love my pension whoa what are
they doing with the blood down there is
weird you guys are weird
everyone is weird in this game I'm just
glad none of them are alive honestly
well I guess we'll have to chop him off
or some weird [ __ ] okay I get it you're
not strong enough but now I'm stronger
now witnessing killing mean
oh are we gonna blow the whistle can you
blow my trombone maybe bum bum baby I
wanted to do it what did just happen ah
don't make do that again the hate it's
how you do it need stronger lungs call
of the what did it say I didn't uh I
didn't get a chance to read it your best
probably got it so I got an achievement
for doing that but why all right we need
to go here I wonder what my achievements
I missed I like though that there is
like that you get points for exploring
or whatever even though it won't mean
[ __ ] oh now we're just back here
maybe we need to follow the river no no
that's not it either
well what the hell yeah yeah again got
it
[Music]
I mean it's I know we need to go there
but how did we make him go there nice
angle
hmm
oh there's a crossbow Nancy it okay
obvious yeah just go up then I'll go
around then there we go all right my bad
sometimes you don't see obvious things I
can't be the only one we're gonna blow
his [ __ ] head off
it's awesome okay now he'd come here oh
say your last prayer Oh Mitch headshot
for a guy this mutilating this dead
corpse
I mean they don't look that bad
I wonder what kill them with so many
dead were they fighting each other or
all these questions
I would keep away from those guys I
would probably stay hidden from those
guys whoa
so much blood now on the [ __ ] did he
jump oh oh oh my god they're full of
blood now it's awesome [ __ ] are they
doing that how am I gonna tell them
apart now it's impossible oh well
[Music]
love these random pots it seems like a
good place to cook right yes that is it
what is it show they're killing
something else ah clean already clean as
a whistle
oh don't want to go down there
are they gonna sacrifice the Virgin she
might have done like something awful we
don't know but she's a girl so we have
to save her right that girl we have to
save her we don't know why but we have
to do it it was a man we'd probably be
like yep they did something bad
sexism in games under scale it's the
controversial topics
I [ __ ] can't go there yes it was
optional to save her nevermind we have
to save her
what the hell is I I kind of statue told
us to do it
what it what is this oh but why are we
doing this oh oh we get we're mimicking
their God we have returned
we have returned let go of the woman let
it go let it go we coming pies oh that
was easy oh my oh they don't even bother
any black however Oh God say yay we did
it they were stupid
[Music]
you know maybe there's a love interest
for the Big Brother mm-hmm
a rabba all right well rabbi you if you
know what I mean
sexism in games sorry all right
ready place now lucky very nice oh well
this is where our journey ends Induna
well I didn't see much else we could do
All Right see you later
okay let's kiss her kiss her goodbye oh
she's coming all right cool
oh god I'm controlling this this is
really weird
Oh God
huh I'm not the best at this I'm
probably not the worst either ah awesome
what is this amazing still blood though
well so much blood and suffering and
just that and fishy's television
are we gonna go okay I thought we were
gonna go inside the waterfall I don't
know why well you gotta give them props
for making them gorgeous game cuz holy
[ __ ] so pretty
sakya - are we gonna go there it looks
like we're gonna go there ah I would
probably keep going with the boat if I
were them say uh Oh what the hell is
that
okay oh whoa
killer whales its killer whales slash
octopuses got it
can we go here yep they go underneath
what I'd say that's nothing let's take
this route cuz I don't trust them don't
kill me please okay
oh god oh god don't go up now so you see
a little bit before oh god oh god oh god
I got it got it back back back like oh
that should have made our boat capsized
but what do I know about life in these
boats I'm dissing sailors in Sweden I
say my blood my back and blood I get the
feeling this is not the type of water
you want to swim anything
all right we did it whoo man was a tough
one
ah yeah high five goddammit coordinate
you're supposed to say one in the front
and one in the back it's like you don't
even know reminds me of a dishonored in
the beginning I don't know why even
BioShock Infinite okay oh why do they
keep doing that shot stockyard red sock
yard or sake on say after me sock sock
hot out of that bag gotta buy whoa
something really big died here keep
going
someone else's journey the same path
assess so pretty got to look pretty for
you breast that's okay I don't wait for
us
she cray-cray
damn I would not do that jump that easy
oh thanks oh where you keep sliding and
stuff guys
don't try it the harder you try the more
you fail it's like the first rule of
sliding and life in general actually
come on jump what's going on what's she
doing there we go I don't know why they
didn't want a gym that she was gonna do
something we ate beautiful like I can
draw in the sand it's not sand sure like
you know I'm from Sweden okay I know
what it is don't hate Oh what the hell
is that a torch one slide in whoo oh my
god they look suck I suck yeah
why doesn't look very happy now let's
save in Spain we are a nice people okay
what the hell what are you doing I got
him he's mine
tireless it for dinner boys I guess we
go up here
[Music]
and then we put them on top of each
other
and then we have a mountain of turtles
got it
or we could just make them slide down
that would work too I suppose
bye-bye
and then they drowned out they're fine
actually
okay oh that's so cute they're back with
her mother or father I don't know how to
tell the gender Nova tour to Isis to be
honest oh he's still unhappy there's one
more where could it be
did I look everywhere maybe there's
something more I mean I didn't see
anything oh there is okay okay might as
well try it
we should do the limits he loved it
look at him that's the face of someone
loving something I think they should
carry it faster - there you go
is your stinking turtle cow oho cheeks
it don't throw away there we go turtle
step I totally call that [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
you're welcome
I have a great life you should probably
go to somewhere hotter like Africa the
same oh you're welcome by the way
no gratitude and whatsoever how did she
lose her son's and bad is anyway no I
guess this is did she just sneeze at all
what time okay I guess we had to climb
[Music]
okay it's probably better to do it one
at a time otherwise I'm just messing up
there we go yeah yeah cute whoa
does that guy freeze trying to high-five
a treat can we see if we can find an axe
this guy looks like it has an axe da I
thought hey let's check over here oh all
that does it
oh I'm a lumberjack around okay I see
falling that in and work all day I'm a
lumberjack and I'm okay I sleep all
night and I work all day you use a la
bocca huge okay I need girl night
anywhere all day I cut down trees ate my
lunch I don't - they're bad hombre I
wish I was a girlie just like my dear
papa you sure lumberjack oh he's okay
they sleep so night and works all thing
did it did it did it did it's a good
song I'm just saying we're gonna saw her
down because she's kind of in the way so
you know technically to make the tree
fall in the right direction
you have to saw on the other side but
what do I know I'm just the Swedish man
you don't know anything about freezing
[ __ ] what do I know about fixing this is
not how it works most unrealistic game
ever I'm just kidding I'm displaying
whoa holy [ __ ] she from a circus or some
who does that who does that
no one does that she's just trying to
show off for the bigger brother I would
say she wants daddy yes
I wish I was a girly just like my dear
Papa whose I'm sorry I'll stop singing
so much death along our way like holy
[ __ ] what happened here oh my god the
Queen lives
I'll eyes that must be living here the
ice queen
yeah that's nice yeah okay fine you know
what make us do all the dangerous part
when you're obviously the acrobatic one
Oh a great war dick blasts here I'm
grant war indeed if only they figured
out how to use the catapult instead of
all just standing there
oh sorry lad with I'll have a seat whoop
all right nope nope nope nope
okay are we gonna shoot ourself in cos
you're cray-cray
she cray-cray she's straight-up
cray-cray
alright bigger brother get it alright
well enjoy your trip
kinetic boy swayin my turn my turn
yo yeah dad that's how gravity works
oh she landed on the other side nice aim
I didn't even see that that's awesome
oh he can pass through yeah forgot my
day
cool city mornin
it's a tad raggy it's an invisible
monster amnesia near Thames Nisha
monster I knew it I knew it I reckon
knew it Bruce
oh my god what is going on here okay
she's telling me to kayak that is never
a good thing
are we splitting our ways here already I
don't like this brooch at Joe's this
doesn't seem safe okay or you could just
do that cuz holy [ __ ] where are you from
why did she ever need to escape for help
escaping from those guys holy [ __ ] she's
[ __ ] Batman Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
who's to say you won't just walk up
straight into us there
we did it but I don't think the danger
is over yet oh oh okay yeah yeah grab on
grab on to it there you go
whoa place is epic it was overrun by
that invisible demon dragon thingy I
killed all the people probably I let go
too soon I'm sorry I feel like an idiot
I'm probably the only one ever who died
there oh my god
one of what happened is if we don't do
it correctly let's go oh it's a pretty
town it's a shame what happened to it I
missed the snow I miss it
saying that in the summer I bet when it
comes I'm through my back it's cold
sure loves to point at things come on
thank you let's look for the shadow this
time I thought for sure that we're over
it there is no shadow that'll explain it
okay I let go automatically to Jesus
crisis ladies crazy no I want the one in
the middle or come on
why did he just eat one of them for
funsies oh my god run run around Baus
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you better not say
anything okay keep going
amazing I made me and me sorry my face
it oh let's spit in there well [ __ ] it
not oh it's so much snowing there's no
point I guess I wonder why they did that
oh we're safe thank goodness oh my craft
we are dead he can't walk in here Kenny
oh don't split up Nahid in my head oh oh
oh he got him save your brother man what
the [ __ ] what happened
buna my can I skip this
come on nahi nahi what is it doing it
wasn't running what the hell was that oh
come on that is bullcrap er I I swear to
God I held down there the trigger I
don't understand why you did one now he
runs see I'm not even controlling this
so why didn't he run there we go keep
running guy how the hell I fail at this
come on you they we don't really know if
he's dead or not do we I love her she
just looks at him
what about Naheed is she what the hell
I knew she wanted him I knew it hello in
Romans this sparks out of absolutely
nowhere oh now they're in love right
that makes sense the hell does that look
like she kissed me that day she kissed
me whoa North Korean a roar I worry abou
always or whatever it's called in
English and sounds more like light and
uh we call it North Korea pretty it's
pretty regardless it's weird I didn't
feel like we were walking north I don't
know how it happened grumpy oh he wants
to go where she tells us yeah even
though it's not the right way I have a
feeling she's an evil witch yeah she's
definitely an evil witch
that's why they wanted to sacrifice her
see I knew it I'm the only one who
thinks about these things such a genius
where's my genius award seriously or is
it I look everywhere every day when the
mailman rings I'm like it's time and
every day I'm disappointed
Oh God is this a spider hole this is
definitely a spider
not a big fan of spiders I don't think
anyone is a big fellow spell oh my god
this is Lord of the load and the ring
soul / game oh my god she's the spider
kick her kick her in the face oh yeah Oh
Han yeah he made out with a spider oh my
god it's the girl from Dark Souls what
the [ __ ] that is [ __ ] nasty okay
[Music]
well I hope you're happy
we need to swing ourselves Rolly cow
whoa wait work holy [ __ ] uh-oh oh no no
night
I'm a ball I'm a ball that's right you
ball [ __ ] let's go out of here hold on
four legs ball attack oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god ball a tank ball
attack ball attack okay
aah ball attack that's right pull out
four legs
this one yours not great that's what you
get for making out with me you're
disgusting you straight-up disgusting
one now which leg that Willy oh my god
you're disgusting
go home Guinea give it a decent AST you
straight-up nasty I'm a ball ba ba ba ba
ba ba ba ba ba
I'm a ball
I'm a ball I'm a ball there you go and
you are own Oh Oh No that [ __ ] got him
oh hell no
oh no he's super dead
[Music]
what the hell is he gonna do now that
wasn't supposed to happen
[Music]
Tory learned Jesus
Oh No
that [ __ ] if only we just escaped
instead of trying to murder her I would
fart on her face or some weird [ __ ] just
to make her feel bad she must be quiet
he must be poisoned now can't be that
much fire left you die a virgin now or
it leaves the spider non virgin Oh God
whoa okay oh [ __ ] be better whoa that's
the tree that's the try it's a try
we did it what are you Bruce come on
we're almost there brother you have to
be
[Music]
[Applause]
we did it it was worth it after all I
knew we could do it I knew it all alone
I knew it now we can he can take it
are there someone living inside the tree
really
ma Lila nobody lower come on hurry up
[Music]
go a little brother yeah yeah save your
little brother big brother
whatever I would run a lot faster if I
was him we're gonna meet someone inside
this is really weird
I'm curious okay there's more stuff
inside what is it that we need to
collect we need to go higher right yeah
to the heart of the tree it's amazingly
the Kokiri to your whatever it's called
the dad mustache tree young man Wow epic
but we need to one of the branches maybe
that's right there we go
perfect
now we're just into climbing interesting
I'm really curious what is the whole
thing in whoa
compared missed I could be our ticket
out of here
this tree is weird man we found it
[Music]
don't just dip your fingers in there
but if it if it's all like a placebo
effect this in regular water or
assumption they say we can jump down
there that's a shortcut I'm still using
both thumbs stick to control it without
even thinking oh alright whatever floats
your boat man oh cool
he better not be dead
No No
come on come on
[Music]
[Applause]
goddammit
how'd it feeling one of them would die
that sucks
well he's sweating his mom now
[Music]
it kind of sucks how they went to save
their dad and one of the brother dying
the cause
[Music]
but with all the dangers we win poets
felt like it was bound to happen
always digging a grave with his hands
yeah
that is hard work [ __ ] so now we just
play oh he's really yeah he's tired oh
poor soul oh come on aim it almost that
Oh
I was pretty [ __ ] out
we have to pull it back yeah we have to
do it oh my god
or naive or soul active berries on
brother how are we even gonna get back
now
and how am i it's gonna be way too easy
to play now with this one brother
[Music]
it's a pretty place to
have a really ruining us
oh he's back
how do feeling we would
well
you're my brother
[Music]
how far will they fly is there that is
that is the question
oh I saw the public
[Music]
the giant castle
how does a bird know where we're going
though I mean we met him here
[Music]
shortcut
okay me bummer if today was there now
let's finish this fight
now the guy from the beginning with the
stick shows up again like hey hey you
just punch his face out is that that's
what I would do
yeah that's where we live oh there's a
stone where our brother could have
climbed that makes me feel sad almost
there
it's weird to play without him now that
we play with him for so long I'm like
huh what am I going
oh yeah we can't swim come on
no no don't give up now
[Music]
come on if it's water
you can't hug ghosts like the first rule
of ghosts you can do an ie don't be
scared
badass neck
you can do it okay he can't swim but
he's not scared of the water at least
now well I guess we go here then hit
real Irma isn't Finn from adventure time
scared of the water - is he doing you
can't walk he doesn't want to walk
anywhere well what the hell what do you
want to do then Majed what the hell what
the hell man he doesn't want to walk
anyway okay what the hell all of a
sudden
are you doing great Naheed I'm so answer
answer I'm so proud of you that's there
oh we need to go here yeah - can you do
that without his brother yes you're
stronger now you have to pull you have
to pull on top of it it's simple physics
unless you're playing then all right
we're gonna have to find a way up here
maybe Oh God what are we gonna do I have
no idea what I'm doing right now ever
touches we're gonna ask our mom
we're just strength of our brother well
that didn't really work did it
what am I missing here
oh oh I got it
watch me look at this
after pull boat trigger and that gives
him super strength he has the spirit of
his brother in him like I was just only
one there you go cool
I figured it out dude you to do dude it
it didn't do well that work here there
to do to new to super jump of justice
yeah save your Papa I did it
looks like the brother could use the
material design yes did it we done Billy
diddly did it
we're gonna go fishing with our dad now
that would be adorable are we going to
our house yep so pretty goddamn goddamn
beautiful oh there is sneak up on him
[Music]
No
[Applause]
[Music]
Brothers
Oh Swedish people made this game holy
[ __ ] I had no idea how probably explains
the same language well there you go
that's awesome uh I really like that I
don't know what do you both think I
liked it for what it was like I I'm
definitely all for more games being
shorter and when I won one experience in
whole rather than just sitting for hours
immersing yourself for like 20 hours
free tiara I don't know it's nice with a
change every once in a while and it was
it was nice for when it was something
it's not like I'm oh I wish to get was
longer but it was nice for what it was
and it told that told the story and it
really felt like I said many times while
playing it it really felt like you are
going on an adventure and I miss that
feeling you know I missed I feeling in
games sometimes because that's how a
game should be when you really immerse
yourself it should be like [ __ ] yeah
we're doing this it's awesome but it was
sad a lot a lot a lot of deaf man I
didn't expect that but yeah I had a lot
of fun playing it I hope you enjoyed and
enjoyed it for what it was and I sure
did and that's all for me I want to
thank you bros for hanging out with me
today and I hope you had as fun as much
fun as I did and that's pretty much all
for me
it's a brofist for you and stay awesome
bros brofist